We had gone through some problems.
So we wanted to integrate this puncture to task science,
Clara's ex from CEO to fire and through engineering or through mathematics,
we realized that it should be part.
And what we did is that we,
the ramp,
the code that would integrate this through Monte Carlo integration and the
garden wall and stuff.
So there is some problem,
there is some insufficient knowledge that we have that we have to remedy in some
way.
So why don't you take a look at the lottery example.
We should reveal what would evolve.
So that seems a great,
this unbelievably difficult function from one to zero.
Obviously this is x squared over pool and the brackets showing your dad.
We have to substitute this form of the fire.
What we get in me on the spot
now let's do Monte Carlo integration plan that we can integrate this function as
we would like to not medically.
So I think three completely random samples of this function.
What does it mean that I desire it?
F of x at wall.
Now if I evaluate this exit one,
I obviously yet are you evaluated?
We,
and I also get that sweet.
So I have free samples now and what I do is I see the average that,
so this is one plus three plus five over three to Andrew's office suite.
I've,
it shouldn't be that right because the address old Phil and how that,
the integration is exactly four times that.
So something that gives back on people,
this multicolored integrations.
So what we know is that three is exactly one for 12 so we see that there is a
difference file off the factor of forum and if you take a closer look at the
integration domain that he will see that four is exactly the size
in fall.
So just empirically,
if we don't,
this is one angle to look at a problem and to solve it you will see multiple I
was,
this is more like the engineering,
the way of solving things.
You don't know how to derive the forehand correct solution that you see that
there is a factor of four.
Four is the size of the integration domain.
Well,
why don't we move to bottle that and see what happens?
And I'll be asleep.
So you can multiply with the size of the integration domain we get the result
that they're looking for.
So let's change the quote.
I want to buy the previous function with integration domain,
which is five zero two five and this is what I will do.
Fine.
And obviously I haven't yet.
I saw that result,
which is the correct some stuff,
whatever it is.
Now this is great and this looks very simple
and just technique seems to work,
but we still have bomb to really know what is happening here.
So we should use some black magic or mathematics,
if you will,
to see what is going on down here.
So imagine that we sample a function with the uniform distribution on cdot.
What does it mean?
I have an interval from zero to Pi and I generate random numbers on it and every
single number has the very same property.
So this function would look like one of her pipe regardless of x in the,
in the parameter it gives.
If that's a matter we spark off the domain.
I choose,
it will have the same problem would be chosen not
what we are essentially doing is integrating your function f of x multiplied by
this salvation.
Why?
Because imagine that some regions of the Faxon would have zero problem needed to
be supple.
So imagine that by integrating from zero to Pi,
the Bible,
all the examples from zero to two.
So there's a region in the function that I'm never going to visit and I don't
integrate.
Right.
So that's one intuition.
Intuition is that if I draw samples,
not with uniform you stupid person,
but with a different distribution that in the average to buy computer,
some regions off the fashion,
we would be over because I have a higher tensile stuff that you goes.
So what we are doing is multiplying is apoe facts with the salmon.
Probably Pee pee of X.
I'll just feel facts is in this case to one of our pilot uniform is to
commission,
which is obviously a constant.
So get out of line at all.
Okay.
And India,
we have the funding in general,
the fashion over pile.
But this is not what I'm looking for.
I just wanted to make the function itself,
so I need to make it disappear.
So I have this one over pilot to buyer,
what do I need to multiply with to get all in his function?
What should the question mark be?
Excellent.
Exactly.
So I just killed this one of our pie will get louder,
which is is the effect something distribution and if you'd take a look that yes,
this is also the size of the depression,
so this is a bit more rigorous.
It'd be boring or swayed to understand what is going on.
This is through a delegation that just empirical stuff,
what should I learn to fly with?
We know that'd be more about what is happening.
I have a sampling distribution that I need to get it done.
So if I have the one over five multiplier,
I got the one incorrectly and if I lose this scanner multifier that I'm looking
forward for that I will get to the correct.
Let's the whole thing
could be 40 feet different.
The Anglos,
I would like to solve the problem,
solve the same problem.
It won't.
It will be put back.
So it's super quick.
Probably the theory,
we have an expected value.
This is what we're looking for.
What is an expected value?
The expected value means that there's a value of something and there's a
probability of getting these values.
So let's take the expected time of the Gospel doesn't work.
I can roll from one to six and they all have the same power or roles have seen
probably p one six
so the values are one to up to six and the probabilities were all the same
losses.
And if I'd have to stop that,
this says that the expected value of the dice roll 3.5 well this means that if I
need,
if I would need to guess
what the next by Saul would be,
that this will be the best value in order to minimize the error for dates back.
No.
If we would like to compute the expected valuable something that this means that
I think the values that is something can pay and I won't divide the problem.
What is it that for instance,
it is impossible possible to the whole seven with the dice.
So theoretically you could put as the something the Saturday there by people,
perhaps it or probably we matters one
and this is the district pays for the continuous case.
We don't really need to do anything very serious.
We just change the summation to integration.
So we are not using the speedy stop you to me continue to stock shelves and
maybe using continuous self distributions.
Now let's introduce this notation.
What I'm looking for is the expected value of this function f of x after an m a
model because it won't be out of the operation.
You need to add more and more samples to get more or is that
not,
what this means is f is the something and he is the sampling distribution
we can do is that we cannot create a discrete some that takes samples of this
fox run and that multiplies with the size of the domain.
And obviously since we are taking the salmon need to divide it by that because
the more sample,
and it was the natural step was the more samples would they fund the function
the larger the number of yet.
So this is yeah.
Region.
No,
you have to take a look at always the key looking at the relevant quantities.
So the expected value of this f of x.
It doesn't mean that in integration I won't apply as with this something
probability and a lot of the right side and the Monte Carlo has to me,
I will have the same as on the left side.
So if I'm looking for the expected way a little x,
I will sample apple profiles.
Yeah,
no.
If you,
if you'll take a look that you can see that this is just an approximation.
This is not be segregated to gold looking forward,
but there is a multitude of theory Reps.
Yeah,
computer science that showing you that if you could use an infinite amount of
samples,
then you will get poached.
The actual
mold courses all want to call it integration,
show you different ways of proving this.
That's this is not what the art leads us to do.
He would just believe that this is what is happening is actually very this,
why does this happen?
You remember seeing his sideway that'd be saddled with all these blue and all.
So you can see that if you have the law of samples,
you look at the destination on Aaron.
Perfect.
Nah,
let's try to use different [inaudible] in a few minutes.
You will see why this would be a good idea in some cases.
So I would like to integrate this f of x and I am out doing the transformation.
That is the identity,
fast relation,
but I didn't do anything to why the facts.
I moved to buy it by p of x and then I divided by,
so this is almost like a scalable the buyer and that might be by him just same
number.
I get the very same thing.
But
if I would like to write that this is the expected value or something,
then this will look a bit different because f over p is the salt thing and he'll
ask perception problem.
So what we have now is the expected value of that.
Okay.
The question is what is the Monte Carlo Escondido for this and what we can put
it in the previous slides that you should be the very same quantity as what I
see in the expected value.
So I will be something f over.
So not only something I'm sadly,
sadly over arbitrarily chosen deep distribution.
Now there are some good meetings on how to do this well and why this is useful.
So if you would like to know more about this,
please leave some of these documents and that's a bad thing nowadays because
I've seen lots of muscle them guidance on all of the power in Russia for a very
long time to find something that has the quality that I shouldn't evolve rather
than people to study.
That's all of the actual examples that we have for use with this form though.
So app over bead times speed.
So I am still integrating Boomi F and a sounding distribution was this two times
science square x.
This was the function that we wanted to integrate and one of her eyes are
stocking distribution,
probably t sorry,
uniform distribution over one.
So
getting back into the original function.
So I'm looking forward to expected value.
That's f over g.
So I'm going to sample in my fault that over.
Let's put this in source code.
If you look here,
I know if I buy the something is to do so.
So it's one over B minus eight so this means one of the Pi e eight is a should
have begun seeing in this case.
So I apologize for that.
The facets of the bowl,
I put the 2.5 in there because if you always,
he is always,
you know that you may light poles that works for integration from zero to
something but not one to someday.
So this is a cool thing to check if you have devoted to this.
So I apologize this age should be zero,
but if you compute the actual results that you would be looking for that need to
look at your pile.
So this is the APP.
Okay.
The first term and the Tommy Line 36 and after the vision we have,
okay,
wonderful.
So is worse and from multiple angles we now understand how exactly this thing
gets work.
Not if you write the goods.
One thing how integration with team and his saw that rendering equation with
this,
what you want to see is that as you add more samples,
we'll see first you're really noisy
and that as you add more and more samples,
this noise will slowly and do you feel,
if you think back either is that her mine we have talked about over and other
destinations off the liberal and this is exactly what shows up.
Also he images.
We are five to Sapele Fatia.
I would like to be interested in the radio spots as I have one more samples
before I converge.
I will get,
I use that are larger,
that'd be excellent at this and I didn't have to use that are smaller.
So this is what shows up initially as malls.
So what you are looking for is always is samples from pixel metric and when you
have a noisy image you would need to know how many cycles I have used for basal
and if it's still noisy Danny,
we need to add more samples.
This is also some visualization on on the evolution of the image after hundreds
and then 100,000 samples depending on the algorithm is multiple ways of solving.
You could have smarter algorithms that take longer to complete one sample
because they are doing soft,
smart magic that this would mean that you will need less samples will be sold,
we'll get reimbursed yet.
And the first I heard from that is actually the naive out off any needs.
Usually it's a tremendous amount of samples,
computer language,
but since he is a simple algorithm you can use your GPU or cvs would dish out a
lot of samples for pixels it ever since.
No.
Oh Pete Dawson beauty break.
This is what we can get if we buy and slash or off base on
this was rather than last founder and some recent example.
Does anyone know who this is?
Please?
Your hand?
Any of the people.
Excellent.
So this is actually Marjorie materiel from the game of Thrones.
Eddie.
Anyone who tells me as boilers,
I was born on that page.
Okay,
so Jeez and this is actuality because the game of false is running.
Obviously we all love the show and there's also steam the,
so there's Thomas all soft surfaces salary.
And you can solve this with a simple office are definitely going to put together
the theoretical part in the second half of this lecture,
the last lecture.
So when I see renders like this,
what I feel is all income parable to religious spiritual wonder.
It is,
it's absolutely amazing that we can confuse something like this using only
mathematics.
He's very simple tools that I assume.
And the other really cool thing is that we are writing these algorithms,
we are creating products that use these algorithms and these aren't,
he's up to world class artists who are just as good as an artist as we are
engineers.
And they are also giving it their best to pre more at four feet or miles and we
can work together to create stuff like that.
So this is absolutely.